parce sanitaires et communication
gouvernementale on en parle avec arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire
bonsoir nous bénéficie merci de répondre
à nos questions ce soir sur rtl france
on l'a vu dix sept mille manifestants
anti-pape sanitaire en ce jour de la
fête nationale alors que le préfet de
police de paris
didier lallement et lui promu commandeur
qu'est ce que ça vous évoque vous le
spécialiste en communication provocation
ou erreur de com
en ce qui concerne la promotion du
préfet de police
vous savez il ya deux manières de la
lyre soit il s'agit de considérer que le
gouvernement juge que ce haut
fonctionnaire a rempli ses missions en
fonction du cahier des charges que le
gouvernement lui avait fixés et donc en
effet on peut considérer en plus casas a
considéré par une partie des gens qui
ont eu maille à partir avec la
préfecture de police ne pas à pic dans
maman dans le cadre d'un certain nombre
de mobilisation sera considéré comme une
provocation que vous avez on va voir
mais il ya parfois des promotions dans
l'ordre de la légion d'honneur qui
annonce ensuite d éviction
donc il faut je crois être extrêmement
prudents pour l'instant dans
l'interprétation que l'on peut faire de
2,7 de cette distinction
on l'a vu il ya eu beaucoup de
manifestations
tout à l'heure que ce soit à paris ou
ailleurs pour dénoncer ce pass sanitaire
le 4 décembre 2020 emmanuel macron avait
dit je cite je ne crois pas à la
vaccination obligatoire pour ce vaccin
je crois beaucoup au travail de
conviction
beaucoup plus au travail de conviction
qu'à l'obligation c'était chez nos
confrères de brut
comment expliquer cette volte face les
français est-ce qu'ils vont lui en tenir
rigueur les 10 et 24 avril 2022
à ce stade c'est très difficile de le
dire ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'actuellement il peut s'appuyer
sur un certain nombre d'études d'opinion
qui montrent que les français ne sont
pas choqués même sont plutôt favorables
ou en forcément d'un certain nombre de
contraintes sanitaires qui empiète
indéniablement sur les libertés
publiques et sur les libertés
individuelles
mais une grande partie de l'opinion je
dis bien à ce stade on va voir ce qui va
se passer dans les semaines qui viennent
semble en tout cas donné quitus à la
stratégie du gouvernement mais n'en
demeure pas moins que ça pose un
problème fondamental ça pose un problème
fondamental parce que quand on lit
l'avant projet de loi est contournée
tout à fait attachée au principe du
respect des libertés publiques on peut
entrevoir dans cet avant projet de loi
un certain nombre en tout cas de
dispositions qui sont à lens et qui me
paraissent à ce stade totalement
dérogatoire des principes qui devraient
aimer zing réussir une démocratie
libérale finalement confier des
responsabilités qui sont des
responsabilités de fêtes de police au
restaurateur est menacé de sanctions les
restaurateurs à ce qu'il n'appliquerait
pas le contrôle des passes salutaire et
qu' ils risqueraient 45000 notamment
voit un entre un an de prison
quand on voit que par exemple les
personnes isolées les personnes qui
seraient contaminés serait astreint à un
isolement strictes sous surveillance
policière avec le contrôle du juge
d'application des peines moi j'ai des
doutes quant au fait que ce texte de loi
puisse passer en l'état le cap du
conseil constitionnel alors il faut
s'interroger sur cette stratégie est ce
que c'est une stratégie qui consiste à
montrer les muscles de la part de
l'exécutif afin de faire coeur d'une
certaine manière à l'opinion est de
convaincre par une forme de contrainte
l'opinion publique en tout cas les gens
qui seraient 4,6 trans d'aller se faire
vacciner
ça peut être aussi une stratégie de
communication c'est à dire qu'on
considère qu'on va durcir le texte dans
l'avant projet de loi sachant
pertinemment que de toute façon ce texte
sera pour partie censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel
mais entre temps on aura
vraisemblablement peut-être dix ont
entraîné un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens à aller se faire vacciner
vous parlez de durcir
et de montrer les muscles vous avez
justement écrit une tribune dans le
figaro
en ce début de semaine avec le titre
emmanuel macron fait de l'autoritarisme
sanitaires un argument de campagne
en suisse il ya le site d'information
heidi point news qui évoque un côté je
cite surréaliste par rapport à tout cela
question simple peut-être un peu
surréaliste également emmanuel macron
est-il totalitaire non mais en tout cas
il a disons aujourd'hui un comportement
qui est un comportement qui est très peu
libérale et c'est ça qui moussent tu
comprends ça qui est vrai sans moment le
plus surprenant aujourd'hui à ce stade
c'est que emmanuel macron se veut le
défenseur des démocraties libérales
souvenez-vous qu'il avait finalement mis
en scène cette cet affrontement entre
les progressistes libéraux dont il
serait le héros et les populistes et
libéraux ce qui est frappant c'est que
finalement emmanuel macron et libéral
économiquement mais que sur le plan
politique il a parfois une pratique qui
est assez libérale alors ça pose des
questions ce qui est assez étonnant
aussi c'est que finalement moi c'est ce
qui me frappe le plus aujourd'hui c'est
que la question qui est quand même une
question essentielle dans un régime
républicain qu'est la question des
libertés
cette question qui devrait d'une
certaine manière inquiète et un certain
nombre de responsables politiques qui
devraient d'ailleurs inquiétée une
partie de l'opinion publique cette
question pour l'instant ce ne semble pas
mobilisé les principaux responsables
politiques et ne il y à quelques
responsables politiques qui se
mobilisent certes et qui font part de
leurs réserves et ne semble pas pour
l'instant mobiliser l'opinion publique
même si je crois que il faut entendre
les manifestations qui se sont déroulées
cet après midi de manière assez spontané
comme un signal faible qui montrent
qu'une partie de l'opinion publique est
en train quand même de se cabrer
n'oublions pas quand même que l'on ce
que l'on a vécu une crise en france et
bien maintenant deux ans et demi qui
était la crise des gilet jaune qui était
une crise aussi d'une remise en cause
d'une décision qui avait été prise de
manière très verticale à l'époque donc
je crois que les semaines qui viennent
vont être quand même extrêmement
importante à ce livre un mois également
vous êtes spécialiste en communication
un mot en termes de communication sur ce
qui s'est passé tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron a demandé à sa femme de remettre
son masque alors
du défilé du 14 juillet tout à l'heure
brigitte macron qu'on a pu voir
également faire la bise à différents
dignitaires on a vu d'autres un ministre
ou autre c'est checker avec le point là
c'est un message différent quel message
on peut on peut y voir nos benedetti
écoutez il a vraisemblablement du contre
et que en l'occurrence le couple
présidentiel avait devoir d'exemplarité
donc c'est certainement la signification
de cette observation qu'il a fait à son
épouse ensuite bon ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises nous on a vu parfois
des comportements
parmi les officiels qui ne
correspondaient pas ce que justement
c'est officiel enjoignent de fer aux
français et il y à là inévitablement
aujourd'hui un hiatus qui se produit
entre disons relâchement parfois des
fameux gestes barrières qui sont disons
ceux d'un certain nombre de responsables
est ce que l'on demande à la population
alors la difficulté c'est qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment tout homme politique tout est
responsable politique est suivie par des
caméras par des smartphones est tout de
suite capté et son image est une image
qui doit être en permanence contrôler et
homme politique les femmes politiques
sont finalement des femmes et des hommes
donc tout le monde qui peuvent être
soumis par moments à des moments de
relâchement mais en effet eux ils n'ont
pas le droit de se relâcher en principe
dernière question très rapidement il
nous reste plus beaucoup de temps a
nominé diéty un mot sur jérôme sert le
mouël directeur général de la santé qui
va quitter prochainement son poste pour
d'autres fonctions
selon nos confrères de france info
auprès du khalife cette information
auprès du ministère de la santé et qui
ont confirmé donc une information de
paris match
votre réaction c'est un
un fusible qui saute dans toute cette
communication encore une fois sur la
crise du commises alors oui est ce que
c'est un fusible qui saute je ne suis
pas tout à fait sûr parce que bon jérôme
salomon était dans ce poste depuis
maintenant un certain nombre d'années
ici il avait été utilisée comme fusible
us en armement ce et là des moments plus
critique de cette crise
mais c'est vraisemblablement aussi la
possibilité le moyen pour l'exécutif de
se séparer d'un gros fonctionnaires qui
sera vraisemblablement un promu à
d'autres fonctions et de faire
apparaître une nouvelle tête à la
direction générale de la santé dans un
moment qui reste extrêmement critique
sur le plan de la crise sanitaire
merci à nommer des métiers d'avoir
répondu à une version est d'avoir
décrypter donc toute cette communication
gouvernementale vous êtes spécialiste en
communication et rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire